Her name's Rose McNulty,
I did not kill my child
We just need this woman to be reassessed so we can move her to the new facility
Rose I want to hear your story
When the war came to Belfast out of the sky he came
Over here
We have to go
You'd better hide
Open up
Tell me where he is
You need to be careful whose side you take with us or with the Brits
It was like stepping into a fairy tale
You're not from around here are you? Are you a policeman?
I'm pregnant.
she was in the car with the priest you know
they're saying it's the priests' baby
What is that?
I committed my memories to my secret Scripture
Do you not understand the power you have over men
You're a priest who also wants to be a man.
Make up your mind but leave me out of it
Sexual behavior of an unborn nature
but I haven't done anything
I think we'll keep you here for a while
She doesn't believe her son's dead
Rose McNulty
There's something missing
I did not kill my child.
Do you think I killed my baby?
Rose!
you know there's a sickness in people that stops them seeing the truth